principale préoccupation des français la
lutte contre le chômage est au coeur de
nombreuses politiques publiques
à 50 ans on y vit la communauté
d'agglomération et ses partenaires ont
mis en oeuvre de nombreux dispositifs
pour relancer l'économie
aider ceux qui en ont besoin a retrouvé
le chemin de l'emploi
exemple tout de suite étoiles abattu
suite je crois que j'ai pas vu
et lors des buts avec quelques chiffres
avec 108 mille emplois sur son
territoire
saint quentin en yvelines concentre un
cinquième de l'emploi du département
par ailleurs l'agglomération contient
plus de 670 établissements de plus de 50
salariés ce qui représente 77 1600
emplois enfin on recense plus de 8800
entreprises installées dans les sept que
nous le taux de chômage à 50 ans nina
reste globalement assez favorable par
rapport aux moyennes
régional et national puisqu'il est à peu
près de 8%
voilà donc la carte qui a été publiée
par l'insee montre très clairement que
c'est un montant en yvelines donc la
zone d'emploi de de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines plaisir et la
zone d'emploi la plus favorisée en
france avec un taux de chômage de 5 2%
en catégories pas avec je disais tout à
l'heure donc des situations évidemment
très contrastées d'une commune à l'autre
mais ça n'en demeure pas moins la zone
d'emploi qui est la plus favorisée
l'agglomération restent mobilisés alors
l'agglomération et ses partenaires ses
partenaires du service public de
l'emploi bien sûr avec pôle emploi et la
mission locale mais également les
services emploient des communes qui sont
très actifs dans le premier accueil
était était demandeur d'emploi souvent
pour une première orientation et puis on
a le secteur associatif également qui
est très bien représentée très dynamique
à saint quentin en yvelines avec le club
face qui règle une trentaine
d'entreprises avec des salariés
d'entreprises qui sont impliqués dans
par exemple du parrainage de demandeurs
d'emploi est qu on a
d'autres acteurs comme le cidff centre
d'information des droits de la femme et
des familles qui propose également un
service emploi pour les publics féminins
essentiellement majoritairement et puis
on a j'allais dire d'autre
d'autres acteurs qui sont issus de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
comme par exemple active ou réagir
chantier dean qui sont des associations
intermédiaires qui peuvent également
proposer des missions de courte durée à
des demandeurs d'emploi mais pour créer
de l'emploi la communauté
d'agglomération oeuvre pour le dynamisme
économique du territoire
exemple avec la maison de l'entreprise
créée en 1999 d'abord effectivement la
maison d'entreprise s'adresse aux
créateurs d'entreprise ou dirigeants
d'entreprises
donc on a deux publics qui sont dans
dans une phase différente
il assouplit aura son origine était
plutôt là pour accompagner les créateurs
d'entreprise les jeunes dirigeants un
enfer de lancement le projet au fur et à
mesure des années elle a évolué elle
évolué parce que d'abord le monde
économique étant en perpétuel mouvement
un perpétuel évolution et puis aussi et
surtout parce que les acteurs et les
partenaires économiques de la maison
entreprises nous le demande nous
sollicitent pour la faire évoluer
donc on a aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de missions qui regroupe à la fois la
partie conseil accompagnement formation
pour les porteurs de projets et des
jeunes dirigeants mende a évolué vers le
financement d'entreprises nous avons mis
en place un outil de financement qui
permet de proposer des prêts totalement
gratuit aux dirigeants d'entreprises et
quelle que soit la bataille d'activité
l'entreprise et la durée d'une
entreprise et puis également des actions
qui sont tournés vers les réseaux
d'entreprise
la personne rencontre un conseiller de
la maison d'entreprise et puis en
fonction des besoins détectés les
demandes du chef d'entreprise
un certain nombre de rendez-vous qui
devaient être proposés rendez-vous
assurée par des experts qui peuvent être
des experts du droit de la comptabilité
des finances d'autres d'autres sujets
donc c'est tout un parcours que l'on
veut complémentaire que l'on propose de
manière gratuite aux chefs d'entreprises
et des jantes 50 en libye on sait que
globalement par année nous recense
environ 300 créations d'entreprises qui
à un moment donné sans passer par une
part la maison d'entreprise et pour les
futurs créateurs voici quelques conseils
de base la création d'entreprise est
relativement simple il s'agit simplement
de bons guides se faire accompagner
il nous arrive parfois de l'oeuf à
comprendre un porteur de projet que son
idée n'aboutira pas on a un certain
nombre de personnes qui se lancent dans
une création d'entreprise et qui sont
parfois même souvent les demandeurs en
toi il vaut mieux ça c'est un conseil
qu'on peut donner il vaut mieux amorcer
la réflexion le projet d'une création
d'entreprise
quand on est au début de sa phase de
recherche d'emploi parce que
financièrement et même parfois
psychologiquement c'est sûrement plus
simple
de démarrer dans ces conditions qui sont
évidemment meilleur que c'est en
arrivant en fin de droit notamment au
niveau de pôle emploi
direction maintenant la maison de
l'emploi et de la formation se trouve
également la cité des métiers
j'essaie de m'inspirer au mois deux fois
par semaine pour avoir a suivi et il ya
beaucoup d'éléments proposé pour être
compétent dans sa recherche d'emploi
mais surtout voir les offres et puis bah
même temps aussi à avoir des idées avec
des conseillers tous à bien gérer
l'informatique les lettres de motivation
les cv et aussi la partie
psychologique où on nous pousse à savoir
comment être dans un entretien par
exemple la cité vie mais s'il existe
depuis trois ans ici sur le territoire
ici on est comme toutes les autres cités
des métiers qui existent en france si on
n'est qu'un risque existe on a tous un
peu la même charte c'est à dire qu'elle
est gratuite anonyme et tout le monde
peut y accéder ici à la cité des métiers
ça se compose aussi avec des pôles
conseil le pool orientation donc on
accueille les scolaires qui ont besoin
d'informations sur leur métier
des informations complémentaires sur
l'orientation scolaire
on accueille aussi des personnes sur le
pôle formation donc la formation si vous
avez besoin d'une information sur quelle
est la bonne formation calais sont fiés
doucement donc déconseillé son apport
inattendu
on a aussi le pôle emploi donc le pôle
emploi c'est une personne qui a besoin
de faire un point d'être conseillés sont
sa recherche au point ça peut être sont
le cv la lettre de motivation ou tout
simplement redynamiser un petit peu sa
recherche d'emploi
et on a aussi le pourrai conversion
changé sa vie professionnelle
le conseiller va informer sur les
dispositifs de reconversion ça peut être
le bio compétences la vae le dif tout
simplement faire un point pour bien
orienter la personne
il apprécie aussi
nos ateliers est-ce qu'on peut aussi des
ateliers des journées d'information et
des métiers
il apprécie être ensemble pas s'isoler
aussi leurs charges en quoi donc c'est
aussi un lieu d'écouté et d'échangé pour
les personnes et pour terminer on
n'oublie pas le rendez vous
incontournable de ce mois de février
la semaine de l'emploi c'est du 7 au 14
février
donc nous démarrons comme chaque année
avec le forum des formations aux métiers
donc à guyancourt avec le forum de
l'insertion également
organisé par le conseil général donc qui
aura lieu à trappes et qui ciblent plus
particulièrement nous demandeurs
d'emploi de longue durée des
bénéficiaires du rsa
et puis ensuite on poursuivra la semaine
suivante avec les forums de l'emploi
donc le jeudi 13
le forum de l'emploi à l'hôtel
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et puis bien
évidemment d'autres forum le forum d'un
terrible à elancourt le forum des
métiers du bâtiment et des travaux
publics à la verrière qui viendront
jalonner dans toute cette semaine
et voici pour l'emploi à saint quentin
en yvelines et maintenant on retrouve
nos actus du mois
ils ont débuté avec une information
d'importance puisque mardi 14 janvier au
théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à l'occasion
des voeux de la communauté
d'agglomération robert cadalbert son
président a annoncé qu'il ne serait pas
candidat à sa succession
il aura passé seize ans au service de 50
ans vivait sans transition sachez qu'en
raison de travaux de remise en état de
ces locaux l'office de tourisme de saint
quentin en yvelines modifie ses horaires
jusqu'au 29 mars
il ouvrira de 13h30 à 18h par ailleurs à
l'occasion de l'ouverture du vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
l'office accueillera du 3 au 16 février
une exposition qui retracera en bande
dessinée les différentes pratiques du
vélo 144 1419 c'est le nombre
d'habitants à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
9,26 1389 à elancourt 28 1245 ait
guyancourt 9100 à manille 30 3567 à
montigny 29 mai 553 trappe
1631 à voisins et s'inclinent 124 à la
verrière un dossier que vous pouvez
retrouver dans le petit quentin du mois
de février ainsi qu'un article pour
faire le point sur les indemnités en cas
de rupture de contrat de travail et un
zoom sur la nouvelle expo du musée de la
vigne consacrée à la culture